to
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
greatest show today this Trisha has
wiggled back into our life emails from
Zak asking me like confirming with me 10
times I'm still coming today
anyways I remember Dennis doing his own
work kept contacting Zack the reason we
first of all were joined today by Trisha
Paytas who we are happy to welcome back
oh I like their shorts I really do you
guys not patty fresh but like okay we're
like a couple now I feel we're all
getting along and like this is ruffle
you told me about your house it's just a
friendship everything has to be sexual I
mean I wouldn't if friendship is even a
stretch cuz this is only our second time
seeing each other yeah and you said like
I'm like oh I'm so glad you guys like me
now and you're like who said we like you
I was like oh like off-camera I was like
I was kidding was it well I mean half
joke I just come back because it helps I
got a lot of like new emails from people
who wanted to like sign up to watch me
like do shits alright thank you for that
there you go you're welcome and thank
you we had one of our biggest podcast
everyone had a lot of fun it was a great
thing that's so we've got Trisha back
here and the reason that Trisha is
joining us today is as you all know IANS
had an season of The Bachelor with h3
instead of a as a capital H and O three
Bachelor and so Ian actually found true
love on a season we had some ups and
downs we had some controversies but in
the end
ian has been dating a girl for how long
in for about since last September around
there since last September he looked so
so he isn't he didn't love any man up on
the show yes yeah so the
the show work no work oh I had no idea
this was a thing and so we take this
very seriously a love is very important
to me and Ella and our community and we
thought Trisha Paytas no that's the next
season of The Bachelorette
so Trisha is here to basically introduce
no it will not it will be incredible I'm
gonna ruin like all these people's lives
just one what guy it's like how do you
how would you bro know someone got some
guys like I don't know I literally met
someone like last like a couple months
ago and I was with him for like 10 days
and like ruin his life and he tells me
that all the time oh what'd you do to
him I think just a lot of maybe like
psychological manipulation maybe doing
it though making a good [ __ ] some guys
like they say we like crazy girls they
say that and you know why I always tell
them I'm like just so you know I'm crazy
and they like what crazy people don't
say they're crazy and then two weeks
later like you're [ __ ] crazy
I feel like they go they go crazy people
don't say they're crazy really crazy
people because I know I ana so people
keep calling me okay I get it I'm a
little like a little unstable but I'm
not like violent so do you have do you
have a personality disorder do you have
some kind of diagnosis I'm a diagnosed
well honestly cuz I've gone to get like
medications I would love to like
medicine do you think I'm when I was a
little kid he put me on like a lithium I
think that [ __ ] me up because I don't
think I was that's what's up for bipolar
I don't think I was and I think it
[ __ ] me up because I wasn't so now I
feel like but I don't know when I'm
that's the only thing I've taken I take
xanax is that a medication like from
Becher's medication for like a disorder
though or just well not oh well well I
don't think a doctor would say that it's
perfect for fun people do take them no
you know it's to treat anxiety you have
a prescription no no I'm just wondering
because listen I'm not judging you I I
was just wanted to go to the doc there
and get a prescribed that he was yeah me
not gonna he may not have been like a
good doctor that's what it is he's one
I'll just give you the X no matter what
like uh maybe fifty in one day if you
want
really yeah well damn load like his
number after [ __ ] you Dan though so you
are with the guy for ten days you guys
were in a relationship I was a
relationship now we are just like he he
was more difficult innate the really
yeah you have sex on the first day
always I did or not even guys you don't
even dates that are going badly so it's
actually been a while like ID I've been
okay with it okay you're okay with only
fans I just like mastery every night
yeah first calm that's incredible that
you found a way to monetize your like
because you you're not having sex you're
masturbating because you're you know
you're not getting it right and you
found a way to monetize that amazing
like I honestly don't even want to have
sex I'm like this is so good every night
like I do it and I get money I get
tipped it's amazing do you ever
masturbate ins and nobody's watching you
like I said this feels like a waste oh I
always felt that you always fill me we
don't masturbate anymore without filming
like the mukbang so if I'm gonna eat a
meal I'm gonna film wow you really have
found every way to monetize it sliders
yeah like this is higher level others
don't have fun unless it's been recorded
that is true and that's not that's me
too because I'm a [ __ ] channel is
there anything else in your life that
you've thought about capturing like film
about the sex acts
you've got the feeding what else is
there left yeah I do my daily life
logging that's I've done I haven't done
dating I haven't done dating here we are
because a lot of people don't want to be
on camera if they do want to be on
camera then you question their motives
and that's what I'm scared about this
it's like are you coming on here just to
me we'll have to decide that together
okay and what kind of people are they
are they like losers or are they like
well-to-do oh well we're imagine we'll
get people from all walks of life you
don't have even a list yet your default
introducing you yes introducing you you
don't have any like prospects not you
know you know we've announced this we
wanted actually to get from you some
information so that now people can apply
I experience even though we're like I'm
older than both of you
I actually looked up here every what the
same wage I forget I'm older you're all
good me yeah oh are you think we're the
same age
oh my god yeah it's not a throttle it's
definitely are getting along good these
don't think of like a little date right
now definitely not a date on you too
much in front of Eli was like obviously
I mean I was offended and repulsed
frankly but it was funny he was really
offended by they were really pissed so
tell me what first of all let's go back
to the ten days with this guy how'd you
meet him Instagram he DM me oh so he was
interested yeah that ever and then when
you and then you saw him you thought you
liked the way he looked yeah no actually
I do not he wasn't my type at all but I
was like this he was so into me and was
like really and not aggressive like the
wrong word I keep using that word
aggressive but like persistent I guess
and I was like whoo I like that like no
one pursues me I'm always the one that's
like let's date so he had an ax he had
an infatuation with you to begin with so
that's probably went to you know ruining
his life because he did did he want more
from you than you were willing to give
is that what happened no I ended up one
he more for him I'm very pushy what a
stranger reaching out to Instagram to
you wanting him so bad that you ruined
his life yeah like it was actually oh my
god this is so embarrassing but yeah him
on cuz he was like so all about me and
then he came out and like still all
about me and I'm just very pushy I to
start talking about like marriage and
kids right away like the first like I
was like please don't ever leave are you
trying to get married yeah yeah what did
I say you can't have kids because you
have triple or triple Emidio kind of I
have like blocked tubes but obviously I
can get like IVF and you can't do a
uterus I'm able to have babies I just I
want to have like I mean adoptions cool
inside but I want to have I got partner
I understand I don't thinks gonna happen
by me forcing them to be my partner but
maybe
never know did you by chance chuckle or
shackle his arm when he came into your
house no I tell you he was hip extending
his trip extra days so part of me thinks
he likes to the craziness of it cuz he's
like you're supposed to only come Sunday
to Wednesday and then he stayed he kept
saying cuz I'll stay one more nails
anymore and I got sick and he wanted to
keep staying with me so when how long
ago did he leave oh my god there's been
like two months now okay yeah and when
he says you ruined my life who initiates
that conversation he does he helps me
still to this day cuz hey Trisha just
wanna let you know you're in my life
where I could assure you like packs
messages I'm you like [ __ ] you like but
what for what what is his explanation
for you ruining his life I think I think
I just like I think I'm very like hot
and cold duh
yeah so I'm kind of like I don't know
people think it's like playing a game
but sometimes I just don't talk to
someone for like a week and then
sometimes I want to like talk to them
every minute of the day
mmm yeah that can be mad at me yeah I
think that's just how I am so maybe
that's why I'm not in a relationship
well guys we have a perfect cat do you
have money
now so I have a really big question are
you looking for guys or a woman or both
I would say guys or trans girls trans
girls now let me just get my Trent I
don't know that if so or that a trans
girl is a man who transitions to a
female mmm-hmm and still has a penis
yeah yeah I'm definitely into
penetration I'm not against dating girls
I've tried it
I just love penis so yup is a girl with
a penis your ideal situation I never
dated them I've hooked up with tons of T
girls I just never have dated them
because I don't know if they want to
date me per se but if they're down I've
hooked up with so many I mean that's
probably how hooked up with more than
the straight man is it really going
Grindr you can find him although I got
in trouble for that too because they
said you're not I'm not supposed to be
on Grindr I don't [ __ ] know the rules
it works for you I think yeah I think
but do they think that you're a man when
they show up no no I
well I don't know what they think I have
to mmm this is so bad I think you have
to go under there I could be wrong I'm
sorry don't crucify me this wrong I
think you have to go under there as I
have to go to there as a tea girl who
also they do is that where the trans
thing came from so did you ever have you
call them two girls I'm just gonna
follow your lead
yeah I don't know if that's offensive
but not okay I don't know your house and
then were like whoa where's the dead I
tell them obviously in chat before yeah
yeah I'm a girl yeah and as it what does
ever like what the [ __ ] um half half or
like [ __ ] yeah but then the other half
are like they're my friends like the
ones I've hooked up with have become
like my friends like their fans or
something like that not fans it's like a
bad thing to say but like they've liked
seeing me on insta and you ever call on
them on booty calls dick calls mm-hmm so
you have a harem of T girls I do yeah
fine credible I know that's why I always
believe like no one's like fully
straight because I've had a lot of like
boyfriends into it and stuff like that
so I always they say everyone's on a
spectrum so and I know this firsthand
because every single one of my
boyfriend's have been like kind of like
into it like autism the spectrum yeah oh
there's a spectrum right
isn't that where you've got your
vaccinations so you're not you're not
gonna catch no you won't catch autism no
but that's like the controversy if you
don't get your kids vaccinated
don't worry neither of us have
contagious offices well that's debatable
I have the size matter we're talking
about two girls were talking about dick
obsession to size matter huh well surely
like there's two small there's two big
any dicks good maybe less than four not
more than eight so anything less than
four inches is too small so you don't
want it too big
yeah definitely not that oh my god are
you guys gonna ask me weird dick sizes
we could feel I think if it's important
to you not like I'm a deal but no but
you you're being very this isn't a
Danish as the a Street podcast it's
actually gonna happen what is this good
news what do people cancel us right away
like after this episode they're like
[ __ ] you guys for not like bashing
Trisha like I feel you're they're trying
to help me this isn't a cosign I just
think you're entertaining me I'm not
endorsing Trisha Paytas I just think
you're entertaining but you're kind of
endorsing me cuz you're letting me on a
platform I mean we that's fine yeah I
endorse you that being said are you
still are you still trans because I
haven't have to talk about because last
time we met you we talked about the
trans thing and it's kind of blown over
but you haven't talked about it and you
still stand by the fact I transmit I do
what I have talked to you girl I know
I'd be a team man and also I talked
about this
I talked about on other podcast I've
talked about it like I just did pockets
to me when I talked about it how I
consider myself trans right but I don't
say it cuz it offends people
I just did my podcast with Blaire white
and she was saying like how like oh now
in person I genuinely like feel what
you're talking about I still consider
myself we've done this okay we're gonna
consider it that bad okay that's all
good so you're a gate you are a gay man
you're a trained to believe we've
established you're a gay man so anyway
but that's fine we talked about it I go
by she and her and it's fine if a guy is
gay a gay man - no you're not
she's a gay man and I'm a lesbian it
worked out oh my god
we're uh we're uh compatible like that I
think like you guys are loved but I also
feel like a lot of people hate you guys
that's very true I feel that too I got I
got a lot be like why would you go on
there they're the [ __ ] worst like
anti LGBTQ bless you oh but that's what
you just said you're a lesbian and she's
trans and you're not funny but see
people don't think it's funny I do here
we go again
I said you but but yeah I agree people
hate me I don't know
I feel like people even my fans hate me
yeah that's weird figure that out
so the Brad Pitt marriage
congratulations on that has that been an
old are you Oh was I here after before
you were announcing you had a big
announcement that you were engaged yeah
that was a troll okay that was a troll
so we can see those so you're good to
date people you're not married yeah not
me okay good did you have sex with the
cutout okay that was obvious but that's
like an obvious troll like my trans
video was very serious like obviously
that was a troll okay okay enough I wrap
it though cuz he can you get him on your
well we might get his application you
never know who would you just die if you
had Brad Pitt on the podcast cuz of me
because of this moment yeah I really
don't see that happening okay i manifest
things like a new big way I promise you
I can manifest anybody into my life I've
always done it I've always done it I'm
really really well sure what was the
biggest Quinn Tarantino I moved out to
LA to meet him and then three days met
him so fast like Oh met him like what
kind of but like it was through a series
of events and I was like literally like
dragged by the hand to like meet him
introduce him and then ever since then
he was always so cool to me like every
time I saw him he was always like so
cool like remembers me like I'm and I
manifested that so quick I'm like I just
wanna go to LA he's just whacking me
quitting Tarantino so I moved out here
and like three days I met him but just
other people just like other things in
my life I've manifested like the podcast
and I have my own podcast when I came on
here and when I was on here I was like
oh my god I could do a friend do my own
podcast in like two weeks later though
you want to a podcast I was like yeah
like I [ __ ] manifest [ __ ] you I swear
you do it manifest Brad Pitt from dad
can you get people from know like yes no
we're not
can you manifest Brad Pitt's penis in
your vagina I mean is that a different
level of am manifesting I just feel like
if you meet a guy that just happen so
you got to manifest the guy first and
then it didn't matter where you what did
you want to [ __ ] Quinn oh yeah because
he's married now my girl what are you
not young she's my age yeah she's
alright well he's old [ __ ]
there the guy was probably big between
them
yeah he's 50 no he's like 55 and there
he's gonna raise the baby in his room
congratulations really good blossom yeah
they're gonna have an Israeli a little
baby do you think do you what do you
think about that age gap are you okay
with an age gap what's your cutoff on
the Lord no I'm okay dude with an age
gap if you're about the age of 25 I hate
age gaps like 18 I like 50 that's
disgusting or like like that's gross
like I'm fine with an age gap now I'm 31
I'm [ __ ] oldest [ __ ] to like we could
both die at any point so I would say 70
is the cutoff so your minimum is like 25
no oh no 35 your minimum 30 25 35 your
minimum is 35 today yeah I've never date
anyone under 40 I don't think really
yeah
I don't know I've always just dated that
I don't know about two girls young girls
they're a little different because I've
never dated them I've always would come
with them so you want a mature guy a guy
with a job a guy who knows a little
about himself job is important you want
a guy with his own money
okay two ends of the spectrum I think
this is where my split personality comes
in I don't think I have one anyways if I
do I was what percent as for it is so I
think like either I need someone really
super rich successful crazy just gonna
take care of me and no long after
mastery on only fans or I want someone
broke so desperate needs me to suck
everything out of me like yes treasure
whatever the [ __ ] you want I got it for
you wanna sleep you want to be yeah okay
so anything really so people should not
apply if they're younger than 35 right
no and your heart oh no no no come on we
got to see what's out there
let's say 25 25 you might get a nice
little twink like Ian yeah I don't want
anyone that looks like you're in are the
interns are the employees I don't know I
don't want any other means only well no
answers how they're all full blown
salaried employees with health and I
don't want that look I mean right so Dan
no rain down on zero to ten no you for
doing this I'm still pissed about it
what did we write well now you get there
now you get revenge
so all one's all one but I'm 10 and is
it
what is it about me that's attack I
would say a nine today I think you went
down a point
oh wow I think your hair is too long it
doesn't in a haircut yeah that's it
nicer I kind of like a little bit of an
[ __ ] and today you've been a lot
nicer Janine a little nicer so I'm a
favor I'm a nicer yeah completely so
okay I have some exercises that I want
to do for all of our thirsty bachelors
out there okay I want to go through a
list of celebrities to get people an
idea of what your physical can you get I
love secrets so rate break these
celebrities on a scale of 0 and 10 being
the most attractive I'm gonna manifest
all these people I'm gonna tell you
you're gonna get Bank gangbanged by a
bunch of all your stars I've been there
done that
have you been gang banked but not by hot
celebrities no but have you been King
Bay um oh I don't think so is that
something you would forget I remember
that's I'm so bad I don't want to like
laugh at about what's the most what's
the most people you've had sex with that
ones I don't think I happen I don't know
what the definition of gangbang I don't
think three or more knocks no okay to
Cox maybe that why I don't know well I'm
surprised you like sometimes honestly
like if you take too many he's like
xanax like seriously you like blackout
you don't remember anything interesting
yeah I try not to do that anymore
yes please I don't I really haven't just
so you know 25 I don't need to be I was
with you 115 once I don't want to happen
again please don't take me away I had
half a xanax this weekend that's it
excellent just a disclaimer so Steve
Buscemi what do we rate him oh I I'm
obsessed with I'm obsessed to see
Buscemi I got a 10 I don't have to just
say a tank he's the all-around
so what tell me break it down what do
you like well first of all I like his
personality I like that okay cuz I'm so
public and like out there he's very like
private and I also mm-hmm he's like
mysterious I love his eyes I love his
demeanor I love that he looks like a dad
like I also just love him like this is
kind of hard to miss LaBrie's because
like if you're a fan you obviously want
to [ __ ] so bad and like Steve Buscemi he
did a yeah he's been with them for so
long like loyalty oh she died I think
right you recently passed but
unfortunate loss for him as a poppet
for you 2009 that astray that's fresh
yeah but I mean you can't move on that
quickly okay so I mean love handbags
okay the first person to compliment his
eyes oh wow that's the thing I like
that's kind of like Gary so Brad Pitt if
he's a panda what's Brad okay I mean
okay I really love Brad Pitt so you see
that's not fair I mean obviously he's at
I'm like okay I don't even talk well
yeah yeah women I don't know whether how
are certain women because we didn't
knock out the dough though I do not like
her oh did you pick all Jewish women is
this like no no purpose because I saw
the other one in Leonard that's not
Jewish Lana Dunham them um she is to
mask so if I want to be with a woman
which is like a tea girl I do what mask
masculine mask from ask you think she's
too masculine I like a femme girl so
like that's why I like tea girls because
they're ultra fun okay so there's so the
most feminine female is a man yeah yeah
with the penis if you think about it
yeah they they go over the top to be
female right like I like a you fun do
you think one will be offended by you
saying that the most feminine females
are men because that's what they're like
taking the title I'm not mad I said
they're T girls the trans girls their
penises is there no girls that are more
feminine than two girls I don't think so
cuz they know it they know it they they
know and they go extreme with it and I
think like a lot of like sis girls I
feel like a lot of times they don't go
all the way they're interesting I'm in
my opinion it is my experience so I'm
just gonna skip the obvious ones here
how about the Sam from Lord of the Rings
I don't know him I don't like him we
don't like him he maybe remind you of
one of our interns which one just in
general
oh for sure creepy College on a vibe
yeah he's David Bowie I mean that's
obvious everyone's [ __ ] no yeah well
never oh not interesting you know like a
song you think I know he's a singer
really yeah and he looks what I don't
like his lips I don't like his plate do
you know you know the Beatles ah do I
know the Beale I mean are you familiar
with their music not a fan but yes I
love Elvis and I feel like they kind of
just copied all this wow so you're a
Elvis person I love Elvis
see if you could get mmm I got in
trouble for saying this but like I've
always just wanted to like [ __ ] him
always like even like his corpse like
anything I just like I'm so [ __ ] hot
to me what about fat Elvis would you
[ __ ] that Elvis that's my favorite
outlets like seven-five Elvis my
favorite Elvis are you fat Elvis your
favorite Elvis
he's wasn't even fat he had a little
extra chunk he sweated profusely which
is so [ __ ] hot he's like eyes his
lips got fatter
oh there's fat this is yeah this is mmm
very sweaty fat I love the sweat oh god
holy [ __ ]
oh my so you like a sweaty fat guy if
you have swag like that like look at his
everything about him do I qualify for
fat swag I don't think you're you might
be Elvis sighs what are you to 10 to 20
yeah okay he was I think he was to 10 at
the time of his death but he was 6 1 ha
oh I'm fatter than he is you are yeah
how'd are you 511 there you go 210
because you do it I'm fatter than Elvis
Fogg and he like well he died from drugs
right you might've been 230 there but I
know at the time of his death use 210
and he died a prescription drugs yeah
okay oh god I love all this Presley so
[ __ ] much you guys have that in
common
who prescription drugs true since he's
dead and I'm still alive but he died at
41 so I got some time Hydra I mean this
obvious everyone's [ __ ] I don't know
him really drunk it's just a dress a
dress a dress I don't think the star
crack and you don't know interest in
cats he was in he wasn't he was in the
wire he's been in a lot of stuff the big
cat the end right yes did you like the
movie no okay no but I James Charles
he's femme but he is a femme boy so no
well whoa he's I think he's too gay I
don't think he's gonna be on the girl
spectrum there's gay boys that are you
attracted oh no no what is it though
because you like the femme with the deck
I think Melanie okay you don't like him
as a person don't know him I just
watched him I felt defranco's podcast
and they both were if you're more
egotistical than Philip DeFranco like
that's bad so I was like canceling
medium you have a problem with Philip
DeFranco
he's very artistic all he ODS wrong with
me yeah that's me in their podcast men
cancelled because like you know many
people cancel me on the podcast cuz like
ok they will ask me to be on but then
the host by now and they'll be like cuz
I have issues with so many people let me
correct you Booker's don't book anyone
without the host knowing that's not true
it is true no it's not I'll tell you why
because there was a podcast maybe was
through my podcast company maybe that's
why but they were like oh you want to be
on this person's podcast I was like yeah
oh no it was true my manager well I'm a
manager at the time he was like actually
she doesn't want you on because you talk
[ __ ] about her husband or something I
was like okay well then why would they
ask me they must have found that out
during the vetting prom
maybe that's it cuz that's the thing I
get I feel like even the philip defranco
when they've like asked me and then it's
always like no but like we've always had
issues like I've always just liked him
even in our food he took your side like
well so go ahead and keep keep thrashing
philip defranco cuz i find that funny
wait but you like him right no he's a
great guy look I'm actually I'm the
fourth most click fated youtuber on this
channel what what for what what was your
scandal no I'm just I don't know but
I've been I've been in like 60
thumbnails oh really yes
are you does that turn you on yeah look
at our interview that I like past Chris
D'Elia and stuff it made me really
excited I was very excited about that
me too I was like I was passing
everybody based I mean the old ones like
post melona Shane obviously are like
bigger but are you one of our toddlers
look what's the order I don't know I
does not like maybe top maybe top
you're definitely top 10 I'll tell you
right now Trisha
okay you satisfied your Papa John though
what the [ __ ] 1.7 yeah Papa John's Papa
John yeah killed it let's see oh oh I'm
not even in the top two life no other I
am no uh three months you'll get up but
look at all the old thumbnail see as far
as the yeah yeah she's actually the
second highest rated episode of last
year yeah I mean the birth only behind
the birth of my son
that was eight months ago my one dream
so I got some time so everyone please go
watch that one you love that Shane is
number one the [ __ ] did that happen
Shane what I didn't even know we could
get shan dazu that my podcast how did
you do this good 9 million views yeah it
did that good I have a different channel
for mine well I guess you guys do too
but this is the original logo this is
right when he started doing his
long-form content yeah like before he
really blew up he loved you guys here's
the ones that's I thought your raisa
podcast was really good he's like you
should do it oh that was nice of him cuz
he doesn't do any podcast so the fact
that he did that it's like that was yeah
I agree that was really nice
so James Charles is a disgusting monster
I didn't say and you hate philip
defranco i great and like and would you
have sex with Phil DeFranco Oh No why
he's got clout he's got money he's old
like me there's just something about him
that's just such like literally dries up
my [ __ ] I don't know what can you love
Jesus and show your [ __ ] yeah hell yeah
Jesus created me okay here we go anyways
would you date Jesus yeah what's his
name oh no James Caviezel I love him
Danny DeVito I'm not as someone who
shamed sighs because like obviously I'm
a thicker girl and some people don't
like the girls I preferred Hall because
I like to look a little what's your
cutoff for tall I mean my bumble 6/1 but
I'm open well we asked for six one yeah
you can put out you can put a height
filter on there do you find a lot of
guys find that disrespectful
well I of course it is but same but but
the way I look at is there's a lot of
guys I don't like to have girls they
want a tiny girl yeah but you can
control your weight you can't control
your height
yeah but sorry it's a preference I mean
that's just wanted it okay look at this
way some guys like there's this guy was
like in love with you only dates like
little Latino women like he loves like
Colombian like that and that's just
never gonna be me I can't control my
race but that's what he likes like
you know some girls only like black men
like you just you can't control what you
like it's a preference but how is it but
that's not true because your rating me
very high and I'm five-eleven
I'm 11 saw enough so you should change
it to 511 six ones you're probably
missing a lot you're also kind of like
famous so the fame help lower the side
yeah because you know who I love is Rick
Moranis and he's 5 3 I feel like you
should lower that 6 1 that's just one I
prefer 6 1 okay so you're like Bloomberg
Bloomberg any mike mini Michael
Bloomberg you know Paul Paul - do you
follow the presidential it was like for
the presidency I thought were nice
Anders in the Democratic primary mini
Mike Bloomberg
his name's mini Mike Bloomberg that's
what Trump calls him okay let's move on
clearly you're not that hot I liked my
last I thought that you might like him
cuz he's a billionaire I mean yeah he's
short huh no I'd rather date a brother
Danny DeVito is out even though he's
wealthy accomplished cute handsome cute
not a fan his work I don't think it's
and you could probably not get some
satisfaction huh you could boil his head
up and use him as a giant dildo I don't
wold either again I know something you
can't control but very picky
I know no but yes six-one no balding
you're like than enemy of men everywhere
no I've gotten some hot guys so Larry
David he'll know he's tall he's a
billionaire he's hilarious Jewish
unfunniest person I've ever watched in
my entire life I watched one episode of
Curb in my ex-boyfriends like don't like
that it's about okay he's like you'll
like this cuz like Lynn Manuel's on it
and I was like okay cool like let me
watch the episode it was the unfunny
thing and I love Lehman Walmart he can
do no wrong way I feel like I'm sure
he's talented
see sometimes talent or something like
that will override it so anyways so I
watch that episode and I was like this
is so unfunny and then I found out he
created Seinfeld or Seinfeld is the
worst show I've ever seen in my life
what the [ __ ] Pass or
what am i doing rate rating yes I feel
so bad I think you'd probably rate me a
zero so well whatever who cares what he
thinks he looks like Elton John I'm not
a fan of the Paul brothers I'm just not
okay he was nice he's really sweet but I
wish to me he blocked me on Twitter
though I mean he blocks everyone I
thought we were homies I see you're an
[ __ ] I think you are like you're so
mean on Twitter but you still were
talking about like my [ __ ] for so long
like you were talking about that for so
long and I was like what the [ __ ] well
well sure yeah but you haven't blocked
me Mike this is Mike Bloom there is no
Wendy Williams just a wild card I like
her
maybe she's see this is the way I like
Tom man but I like short women did you
see her rip ass okay it's not on your
guys's little Club you can I'm gonna
skip oh wait what oh he on my podcast um
y-yeah
what do you mean supposed to yeah I
think he's coming on next week if he
came on to you what would you say it's a
PI would you take a ride what the was is
this is this the you know you just never
know what to expect with a guy like that
okay yeah I think I would with him he
cuz I like wild I like I'm predictable I
think the only person that could be with
me of someone like equally crazy and I
feel like he's a little crazy
do you like the face tattoo yeah I don't
mind a face that too you know
props to the Mike Tyson he got this
faced at a time when doing such thing
was unfathomable now the face stat is
very entrenched people thought when they
saw he's tatted his face people were
like this dude and now everybody's all
these kids are walking around with face
pads Aaron Carter has a face top I mean
awful it's awful this is one of the
worst I've ever seen I don't mind it I
was hanging out with him when you had
the face it looks like Anne Frank who is
a he tattooed on his face tiger really
good tiger it looks like a melted little
girl okay mr. McDonald Mitch McConnell
okay so like when I say 65 I like like
Dennis Quaid not like this like you
don't even mean like you have to have
like swag so know which of the
Kardashians would you none Rob I guess
none of those girls
Robert Godfrey's coming over
Mannis yeah that's gonna close this is
like are these the people you're gonna
get me because honestly I quit I'm
already walking out like I wouldn't just
be single you know I just don't like his
voice all right I heard he's an [ __ ]
I heard he doesn't tap like Rob
Schneider doesn't tap and I heard he
doesn't tip these are obvious yeah Mike
Meyer
oh god you I don't think are getting
like old school Mike Myers looking like
fat all this oh yeah I like him too but
like these he's probably charming all
right well Papa John hell yeah you said
he'd sing all right I'm ready to me he
looks like someone he looks like someone
who might want like a trophy wife like
he probably wants tiny like perfect like
I don't like what about a mistress would
you be a mistress to Papa John I think
I'm all too old at this point
to be and what mr. as they want y'all if
Papa John got you in the bedroom
and he was like there was pizza
everywhere and he said I want to
incorporate pizza in this sex act would
you oblige Wow like inside me orders on
me inside you let's start with and say
he said I want to put the slice inside
you it causes bacterial infection so
what if he says you put pizza in you not
pizza but sauce someone wanted to see
like alfredo sauce because it looks like
um and like it gives you oh my god wait
how much alfredo sauce oh we're talking
about oh I don't know just like drip it
in there that is putrid you have good it
goes into your body like what does it
matter if it's like up there
intravenously like it doesn't matter so
what if he was like I want to do sex act
with you I won't put the pizza inside of
you
I will smother your face and pizza while
I have sexually I'll cover your face
with the unsliced pie oh yeah I think
I've done I don't know before - not
during sex my job for YouTube and stuff
so I would do it for a sec okay and what
if he covered your whole body except
your vagina and pizza and laid on top of
you and you guys had sex just like it's
just his game no but for film us yeah
yeah friends of him or was it kind of
like no it's friends weird dogs you guys
talk to each other
I'll send him your bio did you tell me
what a nine million dollar house so he's
like all right I'll be your friend no I
can't tell him that I feel like only
rule would be from other rich people
everyone told me that soon as I got your
podcast like what why people saying that
everyone tweeted me at all
because I called you poor or something
oh you did call that's right maybe
that's why it's not a fifteen million
dollar house song who was a 15-minute
one company I'm just kidding geez well
okay there's no problem Mick Jagger
Oh is he dead no it looks like it but no
he's still alive yeah Oh No
so these are obvious Jeffrey's are we
just sex with Geoffrey sir oh yeah for
sure I very very much attracted to him
but he's single now
and you guys were just traveling was
there any sexual tension
uh no he likes a man man like he likes
some more I'm with him he doesn't he's
not interested in women not me anyways I
don't I think we just like a good
friendship I don't think it's gonna be
like that if he whipped it out was like
Tricia I need you right now I mean I
probably do that with anyone to be
honest anything yeah but it's - what was
that why is it that you would do that
with anybody I don't know it's like you
think I haven't a somewhat of an
addiction or maybe it's like an
addiction to like attention you have a
sex addiction you feel like well I just
I'm gonna oblige you right now I'm gonna
help you I'm gonna whip their dick out
or something in here
no no I'm just I'm fascinated by that
like what's the limit are you at the bus
stop and somebody whips it out no it has
to be like obviously so many more no way
I can't be like in a bus stop like one
really what about at a bar I wouldn't
suck at the part you do like go home
he's like hey I want to take you home
right now okay yeah and it doesn't
matter who they are people I think no
thank you but I'm very interested by
this see on one hand you're saying six
one and no Bowl at people but at the
other time you're saying hey catch me
somewhere and I probably [ __ ] you if you
show me your dick it just depends on the
mood right it depends on which Tricia
shows up that day
have you had weird nights where you went
with someone strange and it turned kind
of like creepy or bad yeah I'm not
almost been murdered somebody tell me do
you have any interesting Oh we say the
same story they like I've told them on
here I could always see the same stories
I've gotten like shot at a couple times
I haven't heard any of these stories I
don't think I feel like I've talked
about these I got shot a couple times I
got like a hammer like from me yeah no
we don't hand out I always say these
stories that's like kind of boring
really people watch it okay we heard
this I had a guy that just like to like
shoot at your head but he was like
[ __ ] up and so like what he likes to
shoot at your head it was like you got
off like like almost killing you'll be
like I'm not such a good shot like I'm
not going to and you're like shooter
Roger so tell me about the situation
where I was standing
again the house in the house yeah yeah
yeah yeah I was oh my god I was only 22
I was like [ __ ] out of my mind I mean
obviously now some was like let me
should have gone at you I'd be like [ __ ]
no but so where is there a house you can
shoot a weapon in Malvo so it was like
up in like it it's hard to describe like
you know you can go up like a hill and
there's like there's like house on a
hill like a glass house he's wealthy you
know who he is still do I know who yes
tell ya you think he's murdered other I
mean you know no no because he was
shooting a weapon in your head yeah I
know other girls he's on it too though
so it seems only natural to assume that
he may have killed somebody
oh I'm I don't know but I know that you
think you should report that to the
police no because it was like consensual
it wasn't like it was I don't know that
you can consensually murder somebody I
think it's like asphyxia you want people
like to be asphyxiated during exactly
but if you kill somebody during a fishin
it's still man later trip tell me so
will you tell me who is like the house
like ruined after oh yeah but like were
you prostituting at the time yes but I
was not prostituting with him
oh why I just like like to him I should
say oh yeah well it's like wow is he
famous
I hate saying the story cuz I feel like
people start like putting pieces so can
you tell me the whole situation from the
beginning like tell me first of all how
did you meet this guy and tell him just
let's start from there well I met him
through I'm it's gonna sound bad cuz
it's cuz I'm like I'm backtracking but I
did meet him through the person who
booked me for escorting okay go it was
that situation but I told him I didn't
want money I was like oh I'm like really
excited to like hang out like I don't I
don't need money I was just like into
drugs and stuff as I can we just kind of
drug through the denim Oh God
he was doing oxys and
I just did coke at the time we think and
to me that was like expenses I was like
I need all he had coke for you even
though he was doing oxy yeah that's a
man who's prepared to shoot a weapon at
Oprah he had everything he was ready for
Herron I actually only shop here in one
time but he had it at the time I didn't
do it with him but I was too scared he
has like I'm ready like I'll wrap your
arms like this at the time I didn't but
um he had everything so you go over to
his house and is there anyone else there
no just you - and story more but it just
sounds so like stupid and quickly I
sound stupid so I'm fascinated I want it
all had like it was it was it was such a
weird situation because like we hung out
after this happened so as I'm saying
like okay I went to his house thinking
like oh we're just gonna like hook up
and that's it and then after I kind of
felt bad for Mike I just kind of felt
sad and like we would go like this
sounds bad or like I know you were say
like report at the police but like we'd
go to like Chucky Cheese but it wasn't
for anything literally other than like
he wanted to be like a dad and I was
like a daughter I was like 22 or
something so he just wanted to be like a
dad figure you know what I mean what is
this man um fifty I don't know I know
forties maybe he was in his 50s when you
were 22 at the time though you're saying
yeah he's 50 now he looks good no uh I
don't know like in his 40s probably okay
yeah then he was definitely older but
tell me the events leading or the
shooting I feel like people gonna know
because I feel like a lot of girls have
this story and I feel like a lot of
girls are told it well I think this
story is probably I think this guy's
probably killed someone I don't think so
think about it he's shooting a gun in
here but it wasn't like let me kill you
is what I'm saying
well it's pretty close anyway it's just
interesting it's just consensual just so
everyone knows everything yes consensual
I want to know the story I think yeah he
was then did you ever sign an NDA oh you
did but I think I can say it without
saying his name why would he make you
say anything about shooting a gun at
your head
oh I don't know I don't be probably
about NDA's and I talked too much about
Indies are not that they're not no no
there's no way it would
I don't think it would apply when a gun
in India it works when you're like in
business it doesn't work when you go to
someone's house in your doing drugs and
they're shooting guns here you know what
I mean yeah like there are limits to NDA
really of course obviously oh I'm like
rethinking so much in my life this past
year I could go to the police but I
guess like I guess if someone does
something illegal the NDA is null and
void
oh it doesn't have to course and also
you were too young like the fact that
you consented at the time doesn't mean
there's much so many ways for an NDA in
this situation yeah first of all you
didn't have a lawyer you're very young
you're an advantage of you you aren't
drugged I mean yeah you yeah simple fact
that you weren't drugs when you signed
it dealer gentleman really yes of course
well I've got a lot of things to settle
them because like this past year has
been so crazy with NDA's and lout [ __ ]
but like what this year I just signed so
many like under the I told you like last
okay I was sober last time I was here I
had a little like a drug thing at the
end of December but I'm good again but I
feel like I signed so many things when I
was on drugs last year all invalid
really how do they well you know what
trying to date and let's talk about the
the shooting thing because I am
fascinated by this so you go to his
house was this on the first date or the
second thing where he shot at you first
tell me about the evening from you show
up at his house just show up to his
house and then like I just did so like I
was just doing a bunch of coke I think
it was laced with something cuz I felt
so nauseous and sick I wasn't a coke
expert back then I'm still not a coke
expert now so I don't really know I
think it was like probably laced or
something and I just remember being
really hooked up and I remember we had
sex but like he wasn't getting like he
wasn't staying hard you just [ __ ] up
on oxy yeah but you shouldn't see heart
with oxys right usually like mollies and
stuff you get [ __ ] up but or maybe not
I don't think I think drugs generally
don't help ragazze but you guys had sex
so tell me you guys you made up you're
hanging out you have sex and then at
what point does he take out a gun he
just said he could get heart if he could
shoot so we've got to shoot a gun and I
was like okay and I said can you just
stand there and I don't remember I
honestly don't remember for me I like a
left right away because I thought he was
going to kill me because I was [ __ ]
up so I remember I just got in my car
like love but don't but your you're
skimming that I don't remember I swear
to God like I don't want to get this
mixed up because like I don't I've told
this story so many times about the guns
so this is the part we know he pulls up
the gun yeah and he says I can get hard
if I can shoot my gun yeah he's like it
turns him on to shoot guns which I've to
be honest I've heard that for like a few
other guys that they get like turned on
like shooting so the like shoot cans
like in their backyard or some [ __ ] but
did he point the gun at you yeah he told
me to stand over there and just shot
around my head that's what I remember
that's how I remember it
how many shots three maybe and how close
were they on like a wall yeah it was
like I'm literally trying to remember so
hard because like I can't where they're
already holes in the wall yeah oh you
know like if you go to Elvis's house not
to bring up all the sand but like
there's like holes in his TV still like
you know you shot the TV all the time
like it was like Elvis's house and
actually not ironically this guy's a
huge fan of all of us and he talked
about being an Elvis fan quite
frequently so hasn't me do that I don't
know but so you got up to a wall with
other gunpoint and how close were the
bullets could you tell were they really
far over they like no they were close
that's why I was like oh I should leave
because I honestly thought I was gonna
die I would too I mean that's like my
only crazy like shocking story that is
shocking
I don't I don't like this is my life
because like honestly this happened one
time it's happened to like other girls I
don't want to sound like oh my god so
you immediately left did you tell your
associate about it like the guy who's
your pimp I guess yeah there's a girl
and she's like oh but it's so and so so
I was like okay wow that's why I went
out the next day cuz honestly well it
wasn't well they're like that's fine
they normalized it yeah and then it
didn't happen the second day because I
go to his house mmm but he was I think
that's just what people do I think
there's just some kinks people have and
I think some people are okay with it
like I think that guys killed people
know there was a youtuber remember those
that YouTube couple that like held the
book means like shoot me shoot the book
do you remember yeah I know he died but
that was just they're bozos well I put
you up against the wall okay but what
I'm saying it was consensual shooting
he's like shoot me and like okay okay do
you know what I mean like I'm trying to
compare it to that so doesn't sound so
[ __ ] crazy I feel like people are
gonna be so concerned for me like oh my
god well it happen
well it's been a long time right like
what ten years ago
like I don't consensual shooting is a
thing of the past if even if someone has
a gun I'm like oh I actually am scared
of guns like truly like truly but in
fact it's fun for you to find not fine
fine I think it's fine for you to look
back at it now and see how [ __ ] up
that was I get really scared people are
gonna like commit me again that's why
when I tell these stories I'm like oh
god yeah
I was coming at last you're just telling
a stories right now your mental fitness
wow I was a long time ago yeah but I
don't know I get nervous you know it's
such a scary place like I feel like
people can like arrest you on the
internet now like like you have to do
that like you've been committed before
mm-hmm last year who committed you
February 5th 2019 for um it was like an
attempted suicide okay this is not what
this was intended suicide I ran off a
gurney at cedars-sinai and they had a
like restrain me and then I like you're
[ __ ] going to Al Hamra mental
hospital why were you there um oh
because I took too many pills okay so
they considered that unattended suicide
which it wasn't but but yeah but you're
still worried about people like watching
this and then being like we got a packer
away yeah my life if you're ever in a
mental hospital there it's like the
worst experience ever they like treat
you like [ __ ] like there's other crazy
people in there they don't check on you
crazy people just like come underneath
the shower isn't [ __ ] it's like it's no
offense I'm not saying crazy in a bad
way cuz I was in there so [ __ ] I'm
crazy but um yeah it's bad anyways how
long were you in that yeah three days
you have to be in that three days so you
just kind of sobered up and then they
evaluate it and let you go I said that
to my second because you get to a doctor
and I was like I'm fine like I was
[ __ ] drunk or whatever
Wow
that sounds awful all those things not
awful but you survived you're a survivor
oh my god no one's gonna want to date me
after all it's well people like it I'm
telling you okay I'm up fried those are
all my demons they feel well I have a
lot more but oh yeah oh yeah I'm sure
there's many many I'm just scratching
the surface I feel like I'm not so deep
and I felt so weird about it after like
weird
well shape
that's what we do here everybody it's
good it's yes but you're so worried yeah
I know I don't know I could tell when we
got to that part when we started talking
about the shooting you were really
comfortable you didn't want to talk what
if he does come tell me like I don't
know oh so you are worried about him I'm
not worried about him but you think he's
dangerous
I don't think he's dangerous I think you
just never know anyone know about me
like that's why I got blocked by all my
ex-boyfriends like they think I'm crazy
so well I I I am concerned about whoever
that is and I would like a name no I'm
just getting enough to name it but you
make you talk ya know cuz you're gonna
name him I tried oh wow your row you can
I wouldn't name I wouldn't break your
confidence I told somebody I was on a
shitty podcast as on until the story I
told her after like I got out only
people like started like really also
people are gone out and he didn't kill
you anyway okay this is bad
god I get in so much trouble on it cause
I'm fascinated by this story I mean it's
crazy
oh that's like way crazier that than
anything I've ever yeah cuz you guys
have been together what like 10 years
were you gonna do that are crazy yeah
yeah but even sad I watch her guys is
how we met story you said you never like
one out or anything
so how are you gonna get in anything
crazy we've got some crazy [ __ ] nothing
like that though it doesn't even like to
leave the house so yeah [ __ ] of a nine
million dollar house why would you wanna
leave can I come it's not that's it's
not like I want to come where is it
close to here I'm like I'm not gonna say
is it close by 30 minute drive in LA can
I come
you know I am saying no comment about
our house I can't come to your house no
I just don't want to talk about it
mines up mine was out there the minute I
moved in I feel like I was just in there
oh is that legal everybody knows about
it oh [ __ ]
well you know whatever the pie come kill
me cuz I'm by myself you guys at least
have each other so and I'm out there
they put it out there right away like
holla yeah I know it's impossible well
we tried so hard to keep our address
safe and other friends to who bought a
house around the same time there's I
think there's
somebody at City Hall who who they they
tap for that info because we trust yes
we use lawyers and accountants and we
did everything like you're supposed to
buy the water at rice and everything and
they found out in three days
it's there's a website called dirt that
always gets it and then it's owned by
variety and variety publishers I would
like to sue them and it happened so many
other friends messaged me like how does
this keep happening because we're about
to buy a house and we don't know how to
avoid it and it's like it happens to
everyone let me tell you no that's crazy
that seems like crazy that that's legal
cuz when that happened it happened the
day I moved in like three days after we
moved in and you know what we moved
because we were getting swatted like our
that's our safety was was uh I'm trying
to I'm trying to show you something here
cuz I heard that and I was like what the
[ __ ] another thing we guys a Clive or
something is how they knew where you
guys were no no they just it just got
leaked I'm trying to show you something
but yeah it's this guy who owns dirt
calm he has apparently moles everywhere
but variety which is a so they have this
like they have this like shelter calm
but variety does there'd always ones
that publish it so I think it's I think
it's totally insane
and I think that you know I want to show
you the guy this is the guy something
Bad's gonna happen I want to show you
who these guys are because I think
there's a should be sued we could well I
asked my lawyer you know and he says he
says they don't tell you the address but
they show the Zillow listing
yeah they show you everything that in
like it's like showing you one plus one
equals mine they show the number on the
house right exactly
I know actually lives in this
neighborhood and I was like well okay
yeah why late no I want to sue the
modern I have to find a lawyer who's
just got to get his [ __ ] head at us
cuz some of these lawyers are just
trying to find this guy's name he's this
is a guy who owns dirt and he works for
a variety this is the guy here
this is him right here and I just want
to say how do you know that he owns dirt
this is
James McLain editor of dirt variety
editor he's the guy who runs dirt comm
look here's article I'm just saying this
guy's posting our house everywhere so
here's this guy's [ __ ] stupid face oh
my god are you gonna put this out there
James been hired as editor at large for
varieties dirt publications coverage of
breaking real estate news I mean this is
the guy who runs dirt he's dope this is
the guy who gets everybody's address I
don't want to do this I feel like he's
gonna like something bad will happen why
is a public oracle nobody knows James
McLain it's like me talking about the
shooting like it just brings something
up and like he's gonna get pissed at you
if we're talking about it I hope he does
get pissed to me
he needs to know what he's doing is
[ __ ] up we're so brave I this guy's a
[ __ ] he's in danger when you think
about James McLean a variety and there
are doing some of the shadiest most
working people in trains we're doing
this guy he's like the paparazzi they
hate celebrities they're jealous of
their success and they want any I feel
like this guy wants people to die you
have to we were we were our safety was
in danger that's why we moved to begin
with we didn't want to move and this
[ __ ] guy is cool with posting our
address online three days after we moved
so that's James McLean the legend behind
dirt whose docks all of my friends who
have moved and will be sure to die
everyone every single person know it
like gives me such a bad vibe like I
really hate it like you've been talking
about it like makes me scared you're on
this website dirt mm-hmm
the day don't bring it up because you
keep bringing up my house how much your
house cost oh I just rent my house a
rental base docks do on a rental that's
why I'm saying and it's not under
founder my name I have I have a mail
address mm-hmm dude that's so it's um
and but the reason because I did I owned
a house and that was up there and said
you know what let me just like rent this
under a different name all the stuff
like that and that didn't work
good good it's no creepy I want to find
out his address and and make an article
about James mcclain editor of of dirt
look into a beautiful new house it's so
gross see how that feels douche [ __ ] put
your house on there yet [ __ ] so
gross
I got sick
I got Jeffrey security so there's like
lasers on my property now so after like
midnight no for real these are users
yields a people with a laser gun you
can't it's like legal it's like okay so
I don't know how I can tell you the
security people later but like they're
like high-tech so after Jeffrey's like
thing got broken into his like warehouse
he got hired this company [ __ ]
amazing Oh what they're here so you have
late you have leave what is that
acknowledging awesome I don't kill
people
no but you can thank specimens app yeah
you can like stunt people bro you have a
laser gun when nobody told me I could
get laser into my property that's gotta
be expensive and it's not like you're
gonna become friends with Jeffrey's I
know I like his laser gun I want to
fight if someone comes to my house I'd
like to laser their [ __ ] ass yeah
that's what you should do especially cuz
you have like a kid and stuff oh yeah I
have a weapon that was why let me move
cuz we got swatted twice but the story
was with the kid right oh we were in a
gated community with a guard 24-hour
guard oh that's good that I'll hold on
your help but ultimately the police are
called this still better I think so far
the gate the police know that our
address if they get a call
they know that it's likely a phony phone
and the guards know and the guards know
they do wellness checks on me so like
mine but they know now not to come
because I was getting wellness checks on
me like every morning like 3:00 a.m. I
was like okay this is so much yeah
people like has they know like me
history so like were they actually
concerned for you or just no no actually
I've been fine I mean in the past up
I've been like crying I get it like I've
had one those checks per so I'm like oh
I don't want any that's up online
anymore and this specifically in this
new place I kept getting wellness checks
and I was like so annoying
yeah what if you actually kill yourself
then they'll feel bad that's why I asked
them I said well what if I was just like
laying here dead and I didn't answer the
door like well we don't really do
anything they don't like kicking a door
or anything so if you don't know much of
a wellness check more like are you a
live check like you're looks like a flex
finger you up you up yeah maybe they
should just do that okay and then I told
them when I got [ __ ] laser so don't
come on my property and you're like you
have to like have a thing that says it
and stuff like that I don't know it's
like so my
bro what I know be like warning you're
on private rocks like they're being
called like it's loud as [ __ ]
yeah there's nobody balanced or was it
an accident false alarm
someone bounced cuz you know and my
neighborhood people like to check car
doors so like I'm gay obviously but like
the meat was open when I first moved in
I was a whole thing anyways so the guy
was like checking and he like bolted
because like it went off at that time
there wasn't lasers but then I was like
let me get the [ __ ] laser is because
then now I'm property on the property it
sounds like lasers will go up I mean
it's like a stun it's like a stun it's
not like a you're shooting epic as [ __ ]
yeah you'd have to put a warning I think
I think I think it's legal in so many
trouble that one told me I'm going to
jail because I cut up money on my nails
someone's like that's illegal he can't
cut money up it's like a felony oh well
don't worry about that
you think I got really nervous today I
was posting assuming I'm cutting up a
twenty dollar bill I'm putting on my
nails and I was like after I expose you
your own nails no no I went somewhere I
wanted the money inside after I exposed
your earnings you now know that I was
right and that your channel was not he
monetized
right thank you okay okay good Weibo but
to that I really really would see
monetize for so long cuz again why would
I be like let me just show you right now
like why would I do that if I thought it
was actually monetize I had no idea sure
we can't really even debate this it was
obviously monetized the whole time
nobody had a lot of money if I knew that
why would I I think you didn't you
didn't anticipate that I could actually
go in that easy and show your analytics
earnings why didn't know eyebrows like
didn't care like I could have been like
no I'm not doing this I don't feel
comfortable I like I literally thought
that well it's possible you didn't know
his monetize but you were adamantly
defending and saying that it was not
monetized when it was but I got you a
lot of views on your Clips channel
absolutely like Ethan calls herself for
a lie I did you haven't done anything
like that this time what's gonna be the
clickbait for that clip channel today
there's no clickbait let's just get back
to the dating so we've talked so what
kind of man you looking for penis size
four to eight that's pretty generous I
mean your your ket you're gonna catch a
lot of dicks height you like a tall guy
but you're open
I'm open wait chubby skinny anything I'm
up anything huh you're open to anything
I have a lot of skinny guys which is not
my type but like I get a lot of skinny
but I like muscular I'll take a muscle
guy you like it all I like it okay great
what's your dream occupation for them
yeah that's I'm saying I think you have
to be like a billionaire CEO or no
occupation or just on the [ __ ]
deadbeat yeah like I don't so what are
you what are you like these guys cuz
they work they have jobs you have jobs
someone who's just gonna be it's totally
dependent on you so anyone is thinking
about applying quit your job yeah that's
awesome we have a we're gonna happen you
saying tiny dick any size no job this is
gonna be great I like I do like a guy
that's like super rich to I don't want
him between us what I'm saying I don't
like mediocre and okay okay there you
want to cure the other so you have to be
extraordinary shitty human being no
prospects or Tony Stark personality
what's your ideal personality I'm funny
funny mm-hmm I like a funny guy so if
you're not funny if you don't look good
sense of humor don't don't get if you're
a serious person I don't think it's sooo
many serious people would be interested
in you to begin with no I don't think so
either
well not a lot of people are interested
me period to begin with so might be hard
I'm scared okay
no I disagree I think well by the way
GRE do you have any STDs no no no herpes
hepatitis [ __ ] now I had a huge scare
last year with a youtuber who told my
last boyfriend had [ __ ] herpes [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I don't have I would [ __ ]
say it I would say if I had only as sees
you got more curable
I had chlamydia twice oh it yeah that's
it okay yes Oh technically HPV okay
that's fine everybody has that that's
right you know that's what I think if
someone's like known everyone doesn't my
doctor like it's like the flu and I like
all right I heard that 90% of everybody
has HPV yeah heard that too and guys it
doesn't affect them yeah only and women
just get cancer from it not a big deal
yeah it's fine yeah I mean everyone dies
I'm well I'm just kidding actually
so we've got personality whatever
mukbang dude if you want a guy who can
MOOC Bank
oh you want a guy who pulled put alfredo
sauce in your vision no I saw Swan your
vision no sighs no sighs um I I don't
care much about MUC begging because I'm
trying not to do that as much also
trying to lose weight you're trying to
lose weight
what's so hard because I was on your
channel recently it's all eating you
have not been making a very strong
effort I know I almost got some that
cream cheese right here is gonna bring
like who even thinks to do that you
bought french fries it's already
deep-fried and everything breaded
whatever and then you take cheese at
home and you milk it's a popular trend
actually that everybody does that they
put extra cheese so you can get like
everybody ya know if you do mock bangers
eating cheese compilation that's a huge
thing they all but the cheese you're the
better you guys who even thinks do that
it's not your world
you gotta really be into the world I
love my fingers i watch what's in I know
so how many times per week would you
want to have sex
Oh God well my last relationship was
like six times a day six times a day
you got those penis injections I think
it'll dry the last time but yeah do you
mean a penis injection you did a blog
about it I don't know it's like he got
his penis injected with like blood or
some way who are we talking about Jason
Jason would inject his penis he got it
done at like a doctor's I mean he talked
about this is not like a secret hey tell
me more tell me what is it like when we
first started dating it was like sex
like once a week uh-huh and then I was
like wasn't enough for you right so that
was like a couple times a week okay
and then like towards the end he was
getting these like penis injections and
that was like sweet we talked about it
sound like he loved you because I think
that was everything he went got it done
like 10 times I think I don't know if it
lasts forever everybody you go to the
doctor you get an injection your penis
any and how long does that last um I
don't know because we did it right at
the end of our breakup so for two months
I were having sex like six times a day
also it gives you a stimulation for a
while yeah he another girl boner calm
another boner like it was crazy but I
think I keep going back and I think it
could cause like heart problems or
something I don't know there was like
something to it and yeah like killing
the poor guy
I'm for it he did it for a vlog and so I
was like alright for a vlog that sounds
like an excuse well how much of your
penis getting shown a vlog zero I think
David's channel he can show penises I
think he's allowed to do whatever he
wants I'm okay I'm pretty sure that's
not true he is but like do I remember
they like showed going to the doctor and
get it's like a where they mix your
blood and inject it I don't know that
sounds terrifying yeah but I would love
to have sex time today before him I had
time today I think my penis falls off
after doesn't that's a few times know my
last boyfriend before him too was like
it was maybe like three to four times a
day and then my first boy for when his
18 I was like sometime today 7 to 10
times a day he was crazy Anthony Michael
Hall from Breakfast Club okay he was a
sex fiend he liked what no sex like 10
times a day it was crazy I don't know
how that's possible fit to do that's
like when you're at home and there's
nothing to do you have anything to do
this was after dark night and before he
started getting popping again with like
these I don't know these popping but you
say Anthony Michael home I'll say it cuz
I said all day long he's got a huge dick
and he can talk for a 10-10 like this
was your first boyfriend yeah type in
our names together Anthony Michael Hall
Trisha Paytas
who is this what is it I saw he was in
Batman from The Breakfast Club he's from
The Breakfast Club in sixteen Candles
Edward Scissorhands oh yeah I don't know
hands a dead zone he doesn't do much no
there was us
so there was me when I was 18 or not 19
there well he was a bit older he was 44
oh my god was he doing penis injections
no and he looks all creepy I'm not gonna
lie I was in love with him did he like
weird [ __ ] in the sack yeah he was
freaky he's engaged now which is so
crazy because he's been single with no
kids for so long and I was I don't he's
like randomly and guys before you you
don't took my side my side
that was my thumbnail that was a couple
I used it was like how to look innie
thank you so I can look but don't wear
[ __ ] was he into he looks like he's in
the weird [ __ ] um he was just into
really like like Daddy Dom stuff you
know just very like choking in that kind
of [ __ ] yeah why he's doing it he's cute
like I was so in love with him I was so
I mean he he was had like ten
girlfriends but I was in love with him
okay I don't know why did we bring you
there you have it
I think we've got a good overview of
Trisha Paytas mm-hmm
I think that our target demo is probably
give me more along the lines of a
jobless dependence but I wanna also want
like a brad pitt celebrity - can we have
a mix and you said you wouldn't be
interested in Papa John yeah I don't
think those hat in them as cowboy boots
in the ring but I asked
oh he's freshly divorced so it might be
too soon that's my job one kind of girl
Papa John's gonna go after yeah do we
know what his ex-wife looks like I don't
know let's look let's find out I always
think they were married Papa John
ex-wife
let's see Wow yes she's pretty she's a
good Kentuckian Wow a Kentuckian en to
me that could be me in like 20 years
how old she is they've been he said they
were together for like 30 plus years
well damn how does he he's like in his
[ __ ] 60 he look bomb though he looked
like good right or 50s late 50s and he
also lied about not eating 40 pieces you
love calling people out on their lives
cuz he did not eat 40 pizzas in 30 days
well you know he says I had it's like
what come on well I just want to get to
the truth Trish um so we've got we've
know Trisha Paytas we understand the
person we know what we're looking for in
this season of The Bachelorette now my
question is I want to have guys submit
videos we're gonna have you back in here
again in like a week or two we're gonna
have guys submit videos and we'll
Whittle it down to the top contestants
like The Bachelor you've seen that show
yeah with the rose ceremony and
everything so what I would suggest these
guys do is send in their own mukbang
video they can give us a bio about
themselves
tell us about themselves while doing a
MOOC bank ok and how are they submitting
this like on YouTube they're gonna send
us an unlisted video unlisted or listed
I'm gonna just send us a video I'm so
scared no one's gonna apply people will
apply is asking for him welcome
asking for a lot like was it for someone
who's not used to making videos or
Little Caesars but they can't afford it
if they're unemployed little so they can
eat just even one regular date just eat
your lunch do you think I mean it's easy
to do Mook
you can look thing anything french fries
you have suggestions very easy to move
Bank things flat fries yeah just do your
best just be eating something I mean you
want to impress this girl right people
will apply oh my god I'm hoping that
people will at least want to be on our
show minimum at the minimum I guess ok
turn that happened that someone wanted
to see Anna Nicole at her fattest so
maybe someone a one day me kind of
looked that up and remember where she
was fabulous
remember and she like she got this loser
she was on Millionaire Matchmaker and he
like she happy any pickles on their date
in the limo oh man oh is this real
no now that way that's photo shots
ridiculous who would do such a thing so
her arms are enormous that's me my arms
are so big got that thing I think kind
of like insulting so let's get these
videos going guys send them at podcast
at h3h3 productions calm we'll put the
put the email in the description I was
thinking that but I wonder if that will
like do a weird like spam just emails
podcast at h3h3 productions calm send us
your a link to your video don't you
could say whatever you want but I want
to know about you in the video keep the
video I would say maximum it can be
recorded on a phone you know write like
and it yes yeah just tell us about
yourself
eat some food you know we've heard it
all so you have a gem here how much are
you worth I don't know give me a ring I
know how much when you have in my bank
account how much a lot
because I'm kind of cheap I mean I'm
kind of cheap I spent a lot of music
videos i'm kind of cheap but you'll
yield is good you'll treat for it yeah
I'm not a bad boy you'll treat your boy
oh yeah we can live at least 20 years
together if we don't work seven figures
oh yeah I'm ABS we're all youtubers
right eight figures yeah I spend a lot
NES up learning that's why I'm mastering
out only bands how much you make per
session on all of them that's a lot I
showed on my ID showed on my video it's
crazy the amount of money I just started
this like two months ago obviously
people are interested if they're making
money on only fans oh yeah man my only
friends is good I'm not gonna lie like I
want you to make first session are you
comfortable say will you get pay like
daily off of it I think mm-hmm oh you
don't say okay it's like goodbye figures
oh yeah no I mean they won't hit my
profile down I didn't feel like a year
ago and I'm like can you think I'm good
or they'll like keep you on there
forever even Chris Thalia who always has
he hates game he's still on there he's
like I [ __ ] hate this [ __ ] and like
no they don't take your profile down
once you're on there you're on there
forever well I don't want call you out
but I was just curious what they did
take mine down just was not even legit
well I gotta I can get I can give you a
contact there no I know the main guy he
comes up to me all the time I saw that
Beetlejuice on Broadway is like I'm the
owner I see Cameron whatever I don't
know what to take my [ __ ] profiles
everything how much is it to get a cameo
from you I think I used to do it and do
people buy it still yeah I think you're
almost getting expired I'm like I'm not
what do you do then do you deliver them
no no no well what happens to the money
they don't charge them I don't think oh
what the [ __ ]
I'll do a shout out for some I'll just
do it for free I don't care like that to
me felt weird for like a minute I was
like okay I get it I like okay but if
you want to see me like square I'm gonna
charge you you know what I mean but like
you think hi I'll say hi anyway so you
make over ten thousand dollars per only
fans masturbating shesh yeah I could
bring in my computer on that one that's
good money do you think people pay me
$10,000 watch me jerk off maybe guys
like that no guys you don't take a card
of akkad oh he does it he doesn't only
fans and he's like a bigger guy and I
think what makes pretty good I'm in the
top-10 1% I'm like what is it it's a
specific website yeah
yeah it's like oh my god you're calm
it's a Kasai
it's like YouTube for for maybe it's
like twitch twitch for for porn it's not
wife that we actually love now you can
do like I don't do live so you just have
private videos there yes I do like oh I
do like a have to pay to get access to
it yes and then on top of that you can
send videos out for tips so like if
someone wants this very specific thing
like I want to see you [ __ ] like a
realistic hawk or something okay and
that's an extra whatever and the alfredo
video is on there that was so that's a
message where I sent out to all the
subscribers so like a messenger is a tip
you have to pay us yet but it's
available for extra yeah somebody wants
to see alfredo sauce coming on your
vagina yeah only Trish comm is maybe end
of the URL then is really interesting
and well okay we'll get you a membership
for your birthday oh I don't know when
this goes up none right because right
now I'm offering a discount did you did
you get a lot of new subscribers after
our last episode so I wasn't doing when
we can I was doing patreon and yes so I
was doing patron a lot has changed since
our last one so patreon you can't like
touch yourself then I found only fans
and that one full throttle [ __ ] do
whatever and that's where I start make
the money I still do pitch around here
and there but like only fans like took
[ __ ] over it was crazy so after that
I got my podcast and I got the only fans
and it's very it's a weird situation
because people come on my podcast I'm
all serious and then it's like right
after like Sheva dildo up you could you
imagine like after you're done with the
podcast you like you're like I gotta go
like master way and squirt all over the
right it goes on my phone my computer
everything it's like crazy you're a
squirter yeah that's what they like on
there anyone can you can I mean anyone
being right anyone can if you just stick
one of those like massage head things
right in the middle it like causes all
of it to squirrel it just didn't ever
didn't we just proved long ago that
squirting is just pee I mean it's an
orgasm like I can't like are you just
peeing be honest I think there is that
like when okay so sometimes girls like
leak on a penis I think that's being I
think when you squirt it's calm because
you can see it it's not yellow you can
see like the difference between P well P
it mom has a little bit of texture to it
a girl's calm has texture to it like a
guys come does obviously a guy is jizz
is different than P but yeah I'm I think
you put a tarp down
what do you or do you work
my bed is a way your back get really wet
yeah I think I sleep in it like three
times a three times a week maybe I have
like you don't put anything down when
you know it's natural it's [ __ ]
whatever yeah but it's just wet it's
like spilling water on you I think what
do you come and if I can leaks out like
it's on the bed I prefer not to come on
my bed where do you go
I mean somewhere where you can not
fester in your own bodily fluids okay
but like if you're on someone's body I
could still leak over it could score
under the bed but if you have some
spillage or something that's different
but if you just straight-up squirting on
your bed that's a little a lot of
because I feel like it's orgasm but I
love it I think that well sure but I
think the texture that you're I mean
obviously there's like vaginal lubricant
when you yes doing a sex act I think
what you're observing is probably that
mixing with your yeah no it is said that
they say it's like mixed with yarn dan
do you want to see it I'll show you the
video who's the single one out there I
forget what does anyone know there's no
longer so is that boss I'm not like well
you'll have to ask their girlfriends but
we're gonna take care of it
so do you want a guy who's into
squirting oh no I'm not even into it I
just do it firm I actually really like
them every once a very cool do you drink
a lot of water before you do it to
maximize your squirting no I never
thought about doing that I can squirt
pretty far so I don't need to it goes it
goes like down to the wall is that why
you're so popular on there so insane you
know what I found the technique it's
that massager instead of putting it on
your clip put it right in the middle and
then it's all angles well it's probably
because it's just like a like a
gardening you know water all over the
lawn like take your word for it
can I recommend something too yeah
drink a shitload of water for your nose
oh and just because it's that's what I'm
gonna suggest can I give a pro tip and I
think this is your body you're beat dude
you're peeing all over your bed that's
what you're doing that's a pro tip so
for blue squirt drink Powerade I did
that before I drink a gallon of our aid
and it was blue squirt and people were
[ __ ] stuck it was like Avatar in that
[ __ ] no it was blue it me my cuz I
drank like they're like I don't know why
drink two of those like big I drank a
Powerade and it was crazy
oh I have to find that video that one
you need to show on the podcast no you
do drink a lot of fluids before I don't
but I it was just so happened to that
day because I wanted my tongue to be
blue cuz it was a request like can you
have like a blue tongue when you like
stuck like a realistic dick or something
I was like all right and so I is
specific ass requests and I was like
okay and so I had the the blue tongue
and then when I did my thing then I was
like oh my god it was blue a [ __ ]
score everywhere was insane so quick 30
seconds boom then I think everyone at
home just I mean there's all Franklin
there's clearly a lot of guys who are
interested in and meeting you and well I
wanna everybody wants like literally
every guy wants to [ __ ] meet because
no that's not I go bragh that's cuz I'm
like easy it's like okay that's easy
person to [ __ ] but it's like I've never
had a guy but like no I don't wanna [ __ ]
you
I would pass every time and I'm not I'm
only saying that because you just
basically claimed that I want to [ __ ]
you cuz you said every guy I'm saying
like in the situation obviously you're
obviously people who are married I'm not
saying like everyone no I'm saying any
guy that's like encountered me and like
we're already like hanging out okay
we're gonna [ __ ] okay cool I won't take
that as a slight as a way I won't take a
person because you said every guy wants
to [ __ ] me
and I just wanted to make it clear you
think you could [ __ ] me thank you
comment I think maybe you mean that you
don't have any like hangouts that don't
don't end with [ __ ] yeah I've never had
someone like no I'm not into it [ __ ]
you I could see that because I think
guys who are hanging out with you
generally are interested in you right
and so you're up for anything
I think yeah maybe that's the way to go
I've never had someone be like no right
that makes sense yeah sure anyway well
we've learned a lot how much time we've
been doing here Dan
we're at an hour 22 damn that's like the
whole episode I know we why don't you
just be a segment is there anything else
okay I recently found out one other
thing this isn't her into dating is I
guess I have a fat [ __ ] which I did
when I was a thing what does that mean
so I would assume I don't know because I
haven't been with that many cyst females
I've been with movie too
but they all kind of look like my but
like a lot of girls off like a coin slot
which I would assume yours is like a
quick Volger spinner girls yeah so I
just have like a fat upper [ __ ] area I
didn't know that was a thing which I
thought was your gut so I was like yeah
I got a gut but no it's actually like
below your gut before your hole but
isn't that what happened when did you uh
B you get the football oh no but looks
like thin girls can have it too I guess
but yeah maybe I don't know the poop was
like this area like before the gym was
like you know when you see people tucked
in yeah that's like this is no that's a
gut well this is my gut this is a guy so
this is my gut right here yeah and then
the Fupa is this part like gut so is
that good or bad
I have to warn people because like I did
not know this is a thing that was like a
weird thing to people I've never had a
complaint about it but this girl got the
lips the vulva it's something outside
the moment it's like I learned what that
is recently Volvo recently literally
like two episodes ago none of us knew
what the Volvo was really I don't know I
don't know you put you can put a little
like littoral stimulator up into the
bowl but like Lay's there underneath the
labia lips but what's the vulva laser
yeah no don't know what the Volt is the
vowel inside your vagina see she doesn't
know what the move is no no the vulva is
the entire area yeah and I just did a
scene with you okay the - from Adam and
Eve if you put it on the vault no
there's a Volvo so there's a legend
about the vulva
I just researched this because I went
opens what the bulb is buddy apparently
know what right where your [ __ ] and your
labia right there you know you hold it
there so I guess it's not the move but
go ahead you've got to you got Fupa you
got leave there's a it
is it a match would you consider it a
mess no it's nice no there were things I
was fat [ __ ] I've already triggered by
the word fat and I'm like [ __ ] now I got
that busy so I'm just gonna put that out
there to some people I get some people
don't but I've never had a complaint but
I guess a girl told me it's a fat [ __ ]
and I was like oh because I do only if
answer like collabing with girls they're
like oh yeah fat [ __ ] they might have
like a keyway but all that that's kind
of a slate I feel like that's an insult
to call girl you got fat that's what I
thought you know so I'm just going out
there that's right I don't think you
need to put it out there well people
Authority out there I mean the picture
does it more than the words ever would
there you go thank you fat [ __ ] actual
picture yeah when you were making fun of
it yeah well I mean I would have to
sanitize it anyway if we're gonna use it
I don't oh my god oh well before we
leave or should we maybe we should save
this for later for because we're pretty
much done I guess yeah we can
this is Gwyneth Paltrow's smells like my
vagina candle we finally got it we'll do
it next Summa you won't be I'm hope I
know how to get a break here break
before the next time why just be part of
this well you'll be back soon I mean
you'll be back really soon for the next
round h3 should be three people not
[ __ ] two people I doesn't make sense
it's two letters to people but what's
the three H to the third power
it's a EE backwards it's a it's our
names like age for me and three for the
e you get recognized on the street so
yeah you want to go out and see who gets
recognized more that's fun I don't I
don't go I don't go outside anymore
because oh I don't mind being recognized
but I'm with the family all the time
mostly if you have a baby you know what
I don't even live in the house right do
you like don't like is I think these
guys get recognized more than the others
I don't like when people shake my hand
now cuz I'm always with Theodore and so
I'm super conscious about how my how
clean my hands are I like go to the
bathroom wash my hands really good and
like get the paper towel open the door
and then I'm I'm really good and then
someone will come and say hi and usually
before theater I'm always shaking hands
giving hugs I'm doing all that but now
I'm like I'm like hey and I'm like
something hi but I don't want to shake
the hand I'm not gonna be rude if they
put the hand almost shake it but then
I'm like I've got the [ __ ] on my hands
so don't please don't shake my hand
really nice to people or you're just
like hey what's up very nice I love them
because there's some people are like
overtly nice and then there's something
we're just nice and then there's some
people are [ __ ] overtly what's
overtly nice I feel like I'm overtly
nice because like because I really don't
want them to say I'm an [ __ ] so like
I'm always gonna be nice to someone but
I don't freely nice like oh my god like
follow me I'll call you back like I get
really excited oh no no I don't know
that's too much I just say hi they say
hey I like you I say thank you very much
I appreciate that I like had people at
my shows like me like kiss them on the
lips I'm like okay yeah we have it
differently yeah well Angie oh kids like
I agree like I think that's really rude
like when I woulda got with Jason's kids
like I hate him if you lookin belt like
that's so weird they don't want to like
it was our unit no I don't mind them
coming up and saying hi one more baby
but just don't shake my hand
I think it's fine honestly even if you
shake their hand I'll shake it's not
like a newborn anymore you know listen
I'm using Theodore as an excuse to not
touch people's hands it's like how do
you know they're not trying to distract
you to take the baby like that no that's
so paranoid oh my god well that's why
what there's two of us but even with his
like grown kids I'd be like I'm like I
can't take a picture right now cuz if I
turn my back on them like what if you're
kidnapped yeah you're right you are
crazy I mean if that's how you go out a
little your [ __ ] tough place tough way
to live man [ __ ] don't even come near me
like that's how I would be I'd like to
see that lets get me pregnant oh my god
you might know someone from this
bachelor got me pregnant that'd be crazy
another success story okay guys so
please so I may give you guys a cutoff
okay
today's a 21st Graham the email address
do your pull your posting overlay right
then we'll add one okay you gonna have
one post cool so here it is a podcast at
h3h3
productions.com we post this tomorrow
and Saturday you guys have two weeks to
submit is that enough time or is that
too long you have one week to submit I
think two weeks is so the cutoff date is
gonna be on 20 so the cutoff days gonna
be a 7th of March get those submissions
in get those mukbangs and get the tarp
down on your bed control squirts you
squirt during an almost sex oh that's a
thing so but but but generally speaking
if you're just having sex pleasure not
come I mean squirt that's a technique
like you I don't like push something in
there to make it like squirt out so
you're not a squirter by nature no
nobody is nobody's just like I'm gonna
squirt at you yeah do funding enhances
your orgasm yes and you're the better
chance of getting pregnant that can't be
true yeah I heard that for real like if
you heard that would you hear that cuz
you're expelling the fluids yeah I guess
you're just like mixing it all together
so it's like better and then you know
what throw your legs behind your head
after sex also increases your chance I
don't know I've never that occurred yeah
Ely used to do that
I'm not buying their head oh yeah I took
you guys a minute huh no no all no it
just it just happened all of a sudden
but it took a while you didn't do
anything different no two years right no
no I mean well maybe like a year and a
half oh really Wow may I stop taking the
pills but we weren't like actively
trying trying right for the whole time
you know what I mean I remember cuz you
guys we talked about that Niles like oh
my god that's the same thing is
happening to me and then you got pretty
eyes like what the [ __ ] I hear it
happens I feel like maybe not me me I
just haven't had sex in two months old
on me wait you first think you didn't
have a spouse who are you trying to get
pregnant from I mean it's anyone will
come inside you but really do you need
the consent of the man I tell them Oh
people ask me like are you everything
I'm like now oh yeah okay so you want
some guy to knock you up the ones I
choose so like there was a guy I was
like in love with like a couple months
ago and I was like oh you just comes
like me and I told him I was like I
don't know I'm birth control but you
know also like I feel like I started
people out at certain age or just like
you don't have a baby Wow I like the
reverse like NBA basketball player so
wait if some guy not if you get pregnant
by this guy then I guess you want to
raise the kid with him
yeah yeah like I don't have this anyway
I don't think he's thinking that far
no definitely not you should know like
oh yeah now I can scare the [ __ ] out of
it use condoms guys don't leave it up to
them
no they're smart because then they get
like this matter line situation where
they're gonna get $40,000 a month from
me because they have a baby with me the
truth is yeah well right cuz you are
gonna be the one paying child support
I'm like the LeBron James have a baby by
me baby yeah
what's that 50 cent that's not let him
see the basket yeah who is the rapper I
have no idea so you're wealthy
successful seven-figure yeah well I love
that worth probably I would guess 3 to 5
million I don't even know what net worth
means when people ask me out what does
that you mean everything together yes
alright thank what is the property value
of your house and all your assets all
your properties and that's your total
net worth there you go - any debt you
have well sure I don't have that I only
have debit cards or one debit card and
my credit cards were awful so I'd have
no kind of hard so I'm a debt so more
than more than 2 million less than 10 oh
ok this is kind of hard cuz I do have
assets with my father so maybe I'm more
than that I don't know more than 10 well
maybe with my dad though how does that
work I don't know you mean with your dad
so he put it under like a lot of his
properties under my name for like if he
like dice or whatever then I don't get
enough to be like legality your dad has
money that's got mega money if you okay
mo I'm really but he never gave it to me
so people always think well it sounds
like um I don't know I don't like to
think about my dad but no he got a lot
of money when I was like 10 we were
always really broke his own company sold
it to like Microsoft like you could look
this up I think it was Microsoft I could
be wrong MK i I don't know something
like that
and yeah I mean like a [ __ ] ton of money
but he never gave me any I quit college
I was like I'm not helping you anymore
and I was like bye yeah so she's got it
all
she has a lot of life experience and a
lot to offer Oh cry that's so sweet
and she's easy to fly so um so send them
in let's go let's make this a greatest
season of the h3 podcast Bachelorette
Season 2 as I'm very much looking
forward to the view as we get Trisha
thank you for coming and joining us
thank you for being up for this
spectacular season - love is in the air
I'm telling you
use a gun at this tank so I'm gonna be
really sad please watch this episode
right you should have said the beginning
people are alright so we won't be today
so we'll see you guys next week and I
won't be here so Tricia will not oh
right PewDiePie is uh gonna be armed
cool as a guest yeah
don't you think and he didn't he was
supposed to be on today but he didn't
make oh you pushed him over for me you
don't like hell no yeah he made a video
run the same time you did all y'all came
for me so [ __ ] hard no yeah oh oh
ghosting Nick acaba Katims yeah he's
going downhill quick like poor PewDiePie
I made a video about you coasting
someone literally sorry I'm the
thumbnail he did the thumbnail you use
except instead of my after picture he
used the bald guy from whose lines
anyway as a Fred his name do you want to
correct the record correct the record
mom people what PDF I said about yeah I
have everybody said he did a whole video
about me and I couldn't even watch it I
was in such a bad place in my life at
that time and I was like I don't wanna
watch us i watch a little bit I don't
even know [ __ ] him I don't like him like
he's not a thing anymore
mmm you heard a year did you buy his
over yeah and you having him on your
shows you're gonna give a cloud
he doesn't need love for me but he will
be on tomorrow
is that a oh no good squeeze are no good
alright guys we will be here next week
and thank you all and have a blessed
weekend we love you appreciate
if you see me on the street I do love
you and I would like to say I but please
don't shake my hand or touch me all
right
[Music]
you
[Music]